welcome to CBS this morning we have new
information about the White House
strategy to defend President Trump from
the house impeachment inquiry according
to the Washington Post the president
wanted his attorney General William Barr
to make a public statement saying that
mr. Trump's controversial phone call
with Ukraine's President had broken no
laws bar reportedly told the president
no but last night the president called
the whole story totally on true quote
but Ben Tracy's at the White House been
so a lot of moving parts here how are
the president's defenders changing their
approach
well good morning so the White House is
doing two things one old and one new
they are sticking with the old line that
this is all just an illegitimate sham
but what's new is that they're bringing
in reinforcements to help fight the PR
battle you know the whistleblower the
one that came out with us oh the Trump
said this and Trump said that at a rally
in Louisiana Wednesday night President
Trump
railed against the anonymous
whistleblower and Democrats leading the
impeachment inquiry concern the
president continues to double down on
his defense there was no quid pro quo I
had a perfect phone call a totally
perfect phone call but at least five
witnesses have now testified there was a
transcript released Wednesday shows
Acting US ambassador to Ukraine bill
Taylor
testified that his clear understanding
was that the Security Assistance money
would not come until the president of
Ukraine committed to pursue an
investigation into president Trump's
campaign rival Joe Biden the president
has insisted for weeks that he can
handle defending himself by himself
well now the president is apparently
getting one CBS News has learned the
administration is now beefing up its
communications team bringing in former
Treasury Department spokesperson Tony
sayyig and former Florida Attorney
General Pam Bondi to help the White
House fight back this is a political
vendetta Republican lawmakers who have
been publicly defending the president
have been warning the White House that
it's losing the PR battle I think
they're working on getting a messaging
team together the White House is now
sending a representative to a daily
meeting on Capitol
Hill where Republicans are coordinating
their message and strategy on
impeachment now during the special
counsels Russia investigation the
president relied on a group of outside
attorneys to represent him including
Rudy Giuliani but CBS News has now
learned that the White House lawyers
will be defending the president when it
comes to impeachment meanwhile former
national security adviser John Bolton is
scheduled to testify on Capitol Hill
today but he is not expected to show up
Anthony all right Ben thank you